Peggy 18
welcome to carrot a country on the roof
of the world in the legendary Himalayas
here I will give you a glimpse into key
rot from the lush forests and rivers up
to the highest mountain peaks and back
down to the depths of its mythological
past
here at at first glance it's an exotic
Kingdom full of wild animals and
ruggedly beautiful landscapes our world
begging to be explored but a brutal
civil war under the imposter King pagan
min has divided the country and created
chaos
you will need bows knives guns and
explosives to survive the open world
mountain climbers called the zone above
26,000 feet the deaths on thin air is
the least of the threats you'll face on
the mountain and if the enemies and
Wildlife weren't enough the avalanches
are fast enough to outrace you at these
deadly altitudes your wingsuit might be
your only chance at survival in these
uncertain times look to our past for
guidance transcend the depths of your
own mind into the spiritual world of
shangri-la you will fight alongside a
mythical tiger and
the evil forces that once threatened
this legendary rally in this world the
rules of reality don't apply but the
consequences are very real all of this
is just a small glimpse at the beautiful
brutality that awaits you what you do
with this world is entirely up to you
this is for the players